hello and welcome everybody I missed you
terribly since we last spoke so thank
you for for coming back here again
hey remember one thing really quickly if
you're watching on Facebook right now
but you want to get the whole show
remember that you can subscribe on
iTunes for that or go to youtube or
become a premium subscriber to the daily
wire where you get this show and lots of
other lots of other great great content
as well okay I want to get to a story
that just absolutely infuriates me I
can't tell you how angry I am by this
I've just been like stewing over it for
the last 24 hours
if you were on social media at all this
weekend you've probably already heard
about it if you were not on social media
maybe you didn't hear about it and also
if you weren't on social media this
weekend I think that you made a very
good choice a choice that I wish that I
had made so the the story revolves
around a bunch of kids from Covington
Catholic High School in Covington
Kentucky they were in DC for the March
for Life which of course happened on on
Friday and there was a great turnout for
that by the way you're not gonna hear
about that from the media you we heard
plenty about this this incident that
we'll talk about but very little about
the hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of people that were marching for the
unborn the day before so these kids they
were in Martin they were in DC for the
March for Life on Friday and then on
Saturday they were supposed to board
their buses and go back to to Kentucky
so they were in downtown again
apparently waiting for their bus so they
could board and go home now the that's
when the incident occurred and the
incident according to the initial media
reports involved only these kids and a
group of Native Americans led by a guy
named Nathan Phillips and the Native
Americans were in DC for apparently an
indigenous peoples March which was
happening the day after the March for
Life
the original story went viral on
Saturday and it was it was that the kids
randomly swarmed this group of Native
Americans and started a berating and
heckling them and mocking them and
taunting and threatening
not letting them leave while the Native
Americans were simply just playing the
drums and singing a spiritual song so
this was yesterday according to the
initial story which went viral this was
a straightforward blatant case of of you
know privileged white boys acting in an
outlandish ly racist manner and that's
what millions of people believed that's
what the media reported that's what many
prominent folks on both sides of the
political aisle said but I'll tell you
when I first heard the story and it look
this is not I'm not like spiking the
football because a lot of people got
this wrong and I didn't kind of thing
I'm just saying it you know here was my
thought process okay well I did I went
online briefly on Saturday I heard about
this story and my first thought was what
you know it just it didn't make sense to
me it didn't sound believable I'm not
saying that it sounded impossible but it
didn't sound believable or necessarily
plausible that a group of Catholic high
school boys would just randomly start
berating Native Americans for no reason
that's the kind of thing that you think
is plausible if you have a cartoonish
idea of human nature and especially of
white teenage boys but maybe it's
because I used to be a white teenage boy
and so I could think back to that and
it's just I can't imagine like you're in
DC with a bunch of your friends and then
you see some Native Americans over there
and you say hey let's go over there and
talk them guys come on
hey fellas let's go do something racist
that's just it doesn't reading this
impossible that could happen it's just
it's just seems very very unlikely
that's just not how people act right but
there was allegedly video of the
incident video that shows that's what
the media said the media said the video
shows high school boys harassing Native
Americans and the video was a
short clip it turns out of a much longer
piece of footage of course the longer
piece of footage didn't didn't surface
magically until like 24 hours later
after the kids already had already been
getting death threats and we're facing
possible expulsion and had been
denounced hither and yon so let me show
you this is what the short clip look
like this is this is the clip that most
people saw on Saturday and that
engendered all of this outrage here it
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so a lot of people saw that video
out of context and concluded that it
definitely shows high school boys
harassing Native Americans I watched it
on Saturday when there was well there's
footage so I I watched it and I I didn't
really I didn't see it I didn't see what
everyone was claiming even out of
context it's just I didn't see it looks
weird it looks strange it looks like the
kind of video that screams out of
context I mean there might as well be a
giant neon sign in the background of the
video saying this is out of context
because you see that you think there's
got to be more to that even if the even
if the boys are the bad guys here
there's just how did this even come up
what was the scenario where these two
groups even met these are just obvious
questions that people should ask and
very few people did also it was claimed
initially that the boys were chanting
build the wall at the Native Americans
well again you watch that clip of the
video you they're not chanting that
that's not that's not in the video which
is which should be a giant red flag
right if if there's a viral story saying
that this or that happened and hey
there's a video to go with it and the
video doesn't match up with the story
well that's a red flag because it again
it shows you that at the very least
there's more to this that didn't make it
on the video so personally on Saturday I
saw the video I heard the story and so I
just I didn't say anything about it I
didn't I didn't chime in I gave no
opinion for or against the students
because I had no idea what was going on
it seemed it's possible that the kids
were in the wrong but or maybe they
aren't but I just I had no idea so I
didn't say it but there are a lot of
people who felt like they did have a
pretty good idea so these kids were
slandered and defamed and doxed and
threatened for a full 24 hours
and they were even denounced by the
mayor of their town denounced by
millions of others including very
prominent powerful influential people in
the media and celebrities and so on
before finally this full story emerges a
much longer video surfaced as usually
happens with these sorts of situations
one of the longer videos is over an hour
long and was shot apparently by a member
of a group called the black Hebrew
Israelites now the black Hebrew
Israelites are a very important group in
this whole situation but nobody even
heard about them until a day later and
by the way the the black Hebrew
Israelites the BH I will call them they
are essentially cult members that
radical fringe people who think that
they're descendants of the Israelites
and they they hate everyone okay this is
their whole shtick they stand on street
corners and they shout slurs and random
passers-by I've seen them myself
downtown I've been downtown and seeing
these these peoples you know set up with
their little display just screaming at
pedestrians who were happened to be
walking by
screaming offensive things oftentimes so
in the video there video you hear them
screaming insults at ran to pay the
video goes on for like an hour before we
even see the students and they're
screaming insults at random people for a
while they even they they're even
insulting Native Americans they call
them idol worshippers totem pole
worshippers and these sorts of things so
they're insulting everyone there's there
shouting anti-gay slurs I mean these are
these are not this is not the group that
that you would think leftists would want
to would want to defend then finally
this group of people they set their
sights on the white kids who are
standing around waiting for the bus the
Covington kids and they the the black
radicals start hurling insults at the
kids calling them incest children
calling them crackers and other points
called him a future school shooters tell
them they should go back to Europe
they as I said they're using they're
using anti-gay slurs the f-word the the
gay slur f-word and so the kids respond
to this provocation by just kind of
trying to drown out the slurs with with
laughter and they start doing these kind
of like pep rally style school Cheers
and at one point one of the kids I mean
you know their teenage boy so one of the
kids takes his shirt off it starts kind
of like dancing as if they're at a
football game or something like that and
so everyone they're just they all have
smiles on their faces they're doing
their cheers or school cheers they're
laughing and singing and sort of dancing
responding to the hate with positivity
now this seems like if you're you know
in that situation and you've got these
people shouting slurs at you that seems
like a perfectly good way to respond the
point is they didn't respond in kind
they didn't respond by shouting slurs
much less racial slurs back at the black
Hebrew Israelites instead they just kind
of like I said they try to drown it out
this goes on for a while until finally
this Native American group comes in now
remember the original story was that the
the white kids I guess track down these
Native Americans found them and
surrounded them and accosted them
verbally but then you see the video
and you see that the white kids are in
the process of being accosted verbally
accosted by the black Hebrew Israelites
and then the Native American group comes
in and walks up to the white kids
playing the drums in their faces and
while this is happening the black
Israelites are still shouting slurs
someone tells us that someone tells the
kids to go back to Europe and so on but
the kids they just continue their
strategy of kind of keeping it positive
staying above the fray they're doing
their school Cheers
I never I watched a video I watch the
full video I never heard anyone chant
build the wall maybe somebody said that
but there was never a point where the
whole group was John
build the wall which is what Nathan
Phillips claimed and and then that's the
incident okay so that's it that's what
happened
it was provoked by the black Israelites
who were racially harassing a group of
white kids then the Native American
group comes in and tries to provoke
things even further it's clear that
that's what they're doing now there are
some people claiming now that oh you
know they were trying to settle things
down and really that's how you that's
how you de-escalate a situation you come
into the middle of it and start banging
drums in the kids faces that's
de-escalation no it's very clear to me
watching it that what Nathan Phillips
was trying to do was provoke them even
more and actually he failed and if there
was any if there was any doubt about
what Nathan Phillips what his motivation
was well all we have to do is look at
what he said after the fact because
after this whole incident that again he
inserted himself into he immediately
went to them to the media and blatantly
lied about the situation he called the
white kids beasts okay you're not you're
not gonna you're not hearing this in the
media he called them beasts and said
that they were they were harassing the
group of black people he painted the
white kids as the aggressors and the the
instigators of the situation he said
that he heroically put himself in
between beasts and their prey and then
he said in a separate interview that the
kids surrounded him and that they
wouldn't let him leave and he felt
threatened
they said he said they were chanting
build the wall at him these are just
lies okay they are lies contradicted by
the video evidence he is a liar this is
a hands up don't shoot level lie Nathan
Phillips apparently is a scam artist who
played half the country a bunch people
just fell for it the media ate it up
reported it as fact uncritically and
these kids have been smeared all over
the internet and cable news because of
it
the main kid that was featured in the
video the one smiling and Phillips wrote
a statement and explained his side of
the story here's the crucial thing his
side of the story is exactly what the
video shows his side of the story lines
up with what you see in the video the
other version the verb version we got
from Phillips does not line up with the
video evidence and never did
and also Philips version of the story as
a secondary issue doesn't line up with
common sense so it doesn't even make
sense and also it doesn't work with the
video but then we have the video and it
just so happens that the reports we're
getting from the kids matches up so I
think we basically know what happened
here okay so what what did we what have
we learned from this I think most people
probably have learned absolutely nothing
but if you are a more observant sort of
person what what what could you learn
from this incident I think a few things
number one and this is very important
your social media hot take can wait for
a day or two we all seem to be under
this very mistaken impression that the
world will like stop rotating on its
axis if we don't immediately offer our
own two cents on every event the moment
it transpires and there are many other
wise intelligent people who have made
fools of themselves
myself included in other cases because
they felt the need to voice an opinion
on an issue as soon as it came to their
attention without waiting to actually
find out what happened but there isn't
much good that can come of it there is
there isn't really any good that can
come out of a an opinion that's just
sort of dashed off and published in a
hurry as if to meet some sort of
deadline because you want to be in that
first wave of opinion about something
that happened
there's just there's nothing good that
can come of it the most you can hope for
is something is neutral that it will
just have no effect but there's no
there's no scenario where some sort of
really good thing happens because even
if you're right in that first wave of
opinion even if you happen to take the
right point of view which will be really
just a matter of luck because you didn't
you had no idea what the what the all
the facts were so you just happen to get
it right but even if you're right your
perspective is redundant and useless
because everyone else is already saying
that that's the stupid thing about the
mass outrage that you see on the
Internet aside from any of the ethical
or moral concerns which are primary but
secondary what's even the point like if
you see a video like this even if let's
just say that that the video was not
misrepresented and these kids really are
guilty of being racist obnoxious jerks
and you know 10 million people have
already chimed in saying well they're
racist and obnoxious
why do you even need to be why do you
need to be the the 10 million and one
voice 10 million other people have
already said it there so you need to say
it too yes I also agree that they are
obnoxious hey everybody just so you know
I agree with what 10 million people have
already said so at best you're just
repeating what everyone else has said so
your opinion is useless
at worst you are going to be a
contributing member of of of mass
hysteria you are going to be part of a
pitchfork mob so why not why not wait
everyone can survive without your
opinion for a few hours
everyone can survive without your
opinion forever and without mine that's
the other thing none of our opinions
actually matter that much that's I hate
to I hate to be the one to break it to
you but you're you you've never said
anything on the internet that really
made that much of a difference that's in
meat I'm in the same kin it's like
nobody really cares how much anyway
which
which I'm not saying that it doesn't
mean that we should stop giving our
obviously I'm giving my opinion right
now but so doesn't mean we stop giving
our opinion but it just means that you
you we can all afford to wait for a
minute because it doesn't matter that
much so you might as well hold off and
so that you don't embarrass yourself and
also by the way so that you don't
participate in the defamation of an
innocent person accidentally so there is
no downside to taking your time before
offering a point of view there is
enormous downside to jumping the gun
second thing and you know it's
unfortunate that this even needs to be
said or that this is a lesson that needs
to be learned but anyway by anyone but
but white teenage boys are not evil okay
again like I said I'm not spiking the
football I've spoken too soon on many
other occasions but I held my tongue on
this one when I first heard about it
mainly because I know that that white
teenage boys don't generally behave like
the villains and some sort of socially
conscious cartoon okay they're not
cartoon villains maybe you'll come
across a white a white guy a white
teenage boy here or there who does
really act like that but but most of
them are not and what are the chances
that you're gonna have a whole school
filled with racist sociopaths we'll all
happen to be you know they all went on
the field trip together what what are
the chances of that it just it seems
like very unlikely but a lot of people
had no problem accepting the narrative
that was first presented because they
really do think or at least want to
think that white boys carry on this way
routinely and these are mostly the same
people who ate up all the rumors about
Kavanagh because they wanted to believe
they desperately wanted to believe that
privileged white teenagers go around
casually gang raping women for sport but
again with that it was it was yes
there are white teenage boys out there
who are that evil
but the idea that you would have a whole
group of teen teenage boys who
coordinate with each other to drug and
rape women it's just it's not impossible
but that is a remarkable claim which
would require some kind of really
compelling evidence with Kavanagh there
was no evidence and with this with this
most recent incident with the teenagers
there was a little bit of evidence but
the evidence didn't line up with the
claim so these false narratives you know
they tell us nothing about white teenage
boys about young white men they do tell
us a lot about the members of the
pitchfork mob namely it tells us that
these people the people in the pitchfork
mob they hate white men hate them
especially young ones and especially
Christian ones and that's why they were
so eager to jump on this because this is
really this shows you this is what they
think of a of a of a young white man
this is what they think a young white
man is so they heard this story about
the Covington kids and they thought to
themselves oh yeah well sure that's
exactly what white teenage boys do all
the time and that's why it's it's been
it's been pretty incredible over the
last 24 hours or so as this as the full
story has emerged as it's become clear
that that this was a false narrative
that Nathan Phillips lied and so on
there had still been plenty of people
who are clinging who are acknowledging
that that there's more to the story now
but they're still clinging to their
initial reaction or at least justifying
their initial reaction on the pin fact
just to quote here there was someone one
person on Twitter said that you know she
said her reaction she had that reaction
because the the sight of that face
talking about one of the team that the
teenage boy who was smiling she said the
sight of that face caused a visceral
reaction so she's admitting that just
the site of a of a young white man's
face is so repulsive to her and so
offensive that she can't help but defame
and slander him it's just it's a it is a
knee-jerk reaction it's a reflex
she's saying that tells you a lot about
her it tells you absolutely nothing
about the about the boys in question
though third thing we can learn is that
the media really is the enemy of the
people I think Trump was right about
that the news media is the enemy of the
people certain types of people anyway
maybe that's where he got it wrong you
said the people but not all people only
certain types of people because if you
happen to be a member of the wrong
demographic the media will eagerly
spread lies about you they will destroy
your life they will send the mob to your
front door they will try to get you
kicked out of school kicked out of your
job they'll incite threats against your
family they will tear you to pieces
if you are a member of the wrong sort of
demographic group and you and you come
to their attention they will not
hesitate to do that to you so what else
can we call them but enemies I mean this
certainly isn't how friends or allies
bathe last I checked so I am a white
Christian conservative man
they are obviously my enemy not because
I want them to be I'm not saying or
maybe I should rephrase it
I am their enemy and they have made that
completely clear if there was any kind
of video or anything that gave them a
video like this or any kind of video
that gave them an excuse a reason the
ability to destroy my life they would
not hesitate to do it but if I was a
member of a different demographic group
or if my politics were a little bit
different they would hesitate so I am
there they see me as an enemy there's
just there's no getting around them and
here's the fourth thing and this is
really important this is less of a
lesson and more of a
warning somebody is gonna get killed
okay it's only a matter of time before a
victim of one of these media led smear
campaigns winds up dead it's gonna
happen and what what will the insiders
and orchestrators of the outraged mob
say then what are they gonna say are
they gonna say oh we had no idea would
come to this well yes you did when you
put a person's name and face out there
and you tell the world these outlandish
outlandish lies about them what do you
think is gonna happen you are basically
lighting a match in a forest full of dry
dead leaves and if somebody finally gets
burned that's your fault and I could
only hope when that terrible day comes
that at least a few of the smeared
merchants will end up in jail because
this is you know this is incitement this
is not free speech and in the meantime
and hopefully to stave off this this
very tragic but I think inevitable
eventualities we need some you know
there need to be repercussions which
means that because unfortunately most of
the people who are targeted in these
situations like these like these school
kids they don't have a lot of resources
all right these are not these are not
necessarily going to be millionaires so
there need to be ethical and generous
lawyers who are willing to jump in and
and come to the defense of the victims
pro bono and sue the des Famers and
insiders into oblivion news outlets that
run defamatory and libelous reports
about innocent people should face severe
consequences celebrities like Kathy
Griffin who encouraged her fans to
retaliate against these boys encourage
them to DOX him which is you know dig up
private information about him and put it
out there on the Internet invade his
privacy
influential powerful people who do stuff
like that they should be bankrupted by
lawsuits
not as I said this has nothing to do
with free speech and this is libel it's
a this is incitement it's illegal and
that's how it should be treated and if
we don't start treating it that way you
know things are things are gonna get
really bad and there are going to be
very serious consequences I should say
permanent consequences for somebody one
of these days all right I didn't want to
I wanted to mention this very quickly as
we we spent a lot of last week talking
about that Gillette ad which was
insulting to to men so yeah this is kind
of in the same vein this is all it's all
part of the same part of the same theme
but a watch cup now I was I was waiting
I knew that some company would do this I
was waiting I didn't know which company
would be the first I've never heard of
this company Edgard watch company put
out an ad on YouTube responding to that
infamous Gillette ad and I think it's
pretty good here it is
what is a man is a man brave is a man
a hero is a man is a man of protector is
a man
[Music]
vulnerable
[Music]
[Applause]
is a man
disposable
[Music]
is a man
[Music]
broken
[Music]
is a man trying
[Music]
we see the good in men
[Music]
okay I mean not gonna spend a lot of
time on this because I've said plenty I
said probably way more than enough about
an ad about a you know a company that
makes razors so I'll say I like that ad
and you see very clearly that the
difference they're building men up
building up their customer base which is
a smart smart marketing idea but just in
general building men up a positive
message that's also encouraging and
challenging saying you know this is what
a man is a man is a man is courageous a
man's a hero a man sacrifices right
which is which is also a challenge to us
as men that you know personally I don't
think that you know I don't feel like I
need to be built up or challenged by
commercials regardless but I do
appreciate commercials that do it well
and have a positive tone and that's what
you find there so there is a there's a
challenge there but it's in a positive
context saying this is what a man is and
and so if you're a man that's how you
should be but the thing is they don't
need to say that last part they don't
need to say the part of this is what you
should do that's already implied through
the kind of inspirational message so I
thought that was great
all right um so I decided that I'm gonna
try and go to the the mailbag the inbox
I'll call it just to be unique I'll go
to the inbox every show if I if I
remember to anyway just to give more
people it's kind of a chance to chime in
and participate so if you want to send
an email to me to give your opinion or
ask a question or or whatever send an
email to Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
and also if you have inquiries about
speaking engagements or media requests
or anything also Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com okay so let me let me check I
got a lot of messages and things over
the weekend
I'll check the inbox Jennifer says Matt
wanted to let you know you are ugly
inside and out Jennifer I think
for the valuable feedback Rebecca says
hi Matt I love listening to your
opinions I always look forward to a new
video of yours to come out I'm a
sophomore in all-girls Catholic High
School and many of my friends teachers
and even priests have made comments
implying or outright saying that they
are against organized religion could you
make a video defending organized
religion especially the Catholic Church
from such criticism thank you
well Rebecca thanks I have spoken about
this in detail I've written about it
other places so I'm not gonna go into
yeah you could find that if you if you
google it I think I will say that the
backlash against so-called organized
religion is the result of many things I
think but primarily it's shallow
thinking especially if you have a priest
who's against organized religion when
he's a member of one but really for
anyone
Freddie Christian who says oh you know
I'm not I don't like organized religion
it's it's relationship not religion if
these folks stop to think about what
they're saying for just a minute they
would realize that it doesn't make any
sense because religion in this context
means by definition a belief in and
worship of a supernatural being now you
can have religions without supernatural
beings but if there is a supernatural
being and you worship that being that's
a religion that's what a religion is
okay so if Christianity is a religion
you can't say well it's not a religion
yes it absolutely you may as well claim
that an elephant isn't a mammal no eat
an elephant as many other things as well
but it is definitely a mammal you can't
you can't just come up with a new
definition for Christianity is
absolutely by definition a religion so
the only question is will it be an
organized religion or a disorganized one
those are the only two options there is
no option of Christianity not being a
religion because if you take the
religion out of Christianity then you're
taking the worship of a supernatural
being out of Christianity so then you've
just taken Christianity out of
Christianity so it's going to be a
religion will it be organized or will it
be disorganized so someone who says I
don't like organized religion though I'm
a Christian what they're really saying
is I I prefer
a more disorganized chaotic confused
version of Christianity which you know
I'm not really sure I see the I see the
plus side to that and in fact that is
sort of what we have in American culture
right now we have a very disorganized
fractured into a million pieces kind of
Christianity where you know everyone
believes is kind of making it up as they
go along makes up their own doctrines on
the fly so that is that is what a
disorganized Christianity looks like and
there is nothing positive to be said
about it
chris writes hi Matt I wanted to share
something with you in regards to your
thoughts on the Jillette ad first off I
agree with you 100% the ad was an insult
I found a very offensive
my wife disagreed and told me it was
fine to call out all these bad things so
men can behave correctly I explained to
her that there's nothing wrong with
saying these behaviors need to stop but
the ad made it seem like the majority of
men brush off this stuff with boys will
be boys when the when most men I know
have never even said that phrase now
here's the interesting part today I was
coaching my son's baseball team and my
older son accidentally hurt another boy
while playing around my son immediately
apologized and I apologized to the
mother the mother was very understanding
and then said boys will be boys it was
then that it hit me it wasn't that I
never heard that statement before it was
that I have mostly heard it from women
in my lifetime immediately after the
game I told my wife what happened and
explained again why the ad was hurtful
to men in the majority of time the time
it's women who say the phrase which is
yeah I thought that was interesting
because when I thought about it and as I
said last week this is a phrase that I
very rarely hear anyone say on
ironically and I never have ever heard
anyone say it to justify some clearly
wrong behavior in a boy but of the times
when I've heard it used in an in a
sincere way it is very often women who
say it and and justifiably so because
usually boys will be boys just has to do
with boys kind of roughhousing and being
you know being active and energetic and
that sort of thing
kevin says what's it like being an
uneducated bigot I don't know Kevin you
tell me
Jordan writes Matt on the Covington
Catholic school kids issue you may be
right that the issue with misconstrued
you may be right that Phillips lied but
still they were disrespectful and
obnoxious and they deserve the criticism
I feel like you're just trying to be a
contrarian by defending them lost some
respect for you today and I say this as
a fan disrespectful and obnoxious now
you tell me what do they suppose what's
the protocol here what are they supposed
to do these kids again they were just
standing there they're being harassed
and and and verbally assaulted by this
black radical group and then these this
Native American group marches in starts
playing a drum in their face what how
are you supposed to react when I look
through that video you know the main
thing I saw on the faces of these kids
and there's there's been a lot of a lot
of people have had a lot to say about
the facial expressions of these white
kids especially the one the main one
featured in the video and how he's
smiling and everything and people are
making a lot out of that but the main
thing that I see is they're just they're
they're perplexed what I see is
confusion they don't know what the hell
is going on and they're they're just so
they're kind of it's a nervous sort of
laughter of it's the kind of thing you
do where you're like okay that it was
that kind of smile as in why is this guy
coming in here and playing the drum of
my face exactly who are these people
over here shouting all this stuff about
about you know it was they were confused
so how are you supposed to react if you
were in that exact situation Jordan and
but you had never heard of this before
so you weren't prepared for it what
would you do
were they supposed to lie down in the
fetal position were they supposed to bow
down and in worship I mean what are they
supposed to do and I'll well I will also
say that I believe completely in
respecting your elders but this guy it
appears to me he was trying to provoke
these kids and then he went and turned
around called them beasts and lied about
them so this is not a man who was were
of very much respect because you know
you can you can lose your right to
respect and when you lie and slander and
defame somebody and try to manipulate
and coerce a situation and all that you
just you're you're just not worthy of
that much respect I'm sorry it's got
nothing to do with you being Native
Americans just has to do with you being
a liar
and finally Mitchell writes Matt I saw
you kissing Tom Brady's butt on Twitter
not literally you didn't see that I
thought I admired you but now I have to
reconsider were steak I've ever seen
Brady is an overrated cheater look I'm
sorry I hate the Patriots with a passion
and I don't like Tom Brady but what Tom
Brady is doing we know player in the NFL
has ever done anything like this this is
this is the greatest NFL player to ever
play the game without a doubt there's
not even a discussion anymore there's no
one else who you could possibly put in
this category because no other NFL
player dominated to this extent for two
decades now some of the other great QB
is you can think of we're very dominant
for you know seven or eight years
sometimes a decade but two decades Tom
Brady came into the league I think in
2003 it's not 2019 that's almost two
entire decades and he's going to is uh
to yet another Super Bowl so to be this
good for this long against this level of
competition now you might know you might
say the AFC East is a pretty weak
division and it is but just in general
in the NFL the athletes are so good so
everyone you're playing against is
really really good these days it's not
like it's not like the NFL in the 60s
when you'd be playing a bunch of against
a bunch of just sort of like ordinary
dad type people no these days these are
just athletic machines that you're
playing against and so for Tom Brady to
be this good for that long it's it is
the only other professional athlete that
is maybe as impressive as Tom Brady is
LeBron James who again there's really
no discussion there anymore he's
obviously the best basketball player to
ever ever play the game and I'm sure we
can all agree on that we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening listening Godspeed